[Applaudissements]
vous êtes vraiment tout comme mathieu a
menti oui c'est vrai oui oui dit quoi à
la rentrée je vous ai fait croire parce
que j'avais déjà eu la réponse en fait
que pour danse avec les stars je ne
savais pas trop pour vous mon premier
mais c'est grave ça
pourquoi ces gravats en paix tu as fait
tu m'avais dit mme aviez dit que vous
avez vous une réponse parce qu'il ya
peut-être danse avec les stars qui ne
veulent donc faut que vous me donniez
une réponse vite fait du côté ok bah oui
c'est bon d'accord les effets tangibles
ça vous choque énormément
pourquoi j'ai pas là pas le droit ah oui
peut pas la renvoyer à titre vous êtes
vraiment un bon camarade
ça fait plaisir avec ses dangers ce prix
de la chronique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]